there are as with many questions there
are easy ways and hard ways to have a go
at this
so part of what makes it a bit icky is
that you've got these fractions on
fractions which are kind of gross and as
I write it up on the board here I'm
gonna take the opportunity to encourage
you all when you have fractions on
fractions because sometimes you kind of
wait it to put some extra brackets just
to help you out you don't have to do
those I think it's clear from that
writing but it's so forth yeah say it
again so are you suggesting we could
convert this to index form okay so we
know that we can write our fractions
like this as X to the power of minus 1
right so that could be something that I
do and that would avoid the fractions
right X to the minus 1 on 1 plus X to
the minus 1 and I'd be totally okay with
that right so at least I don't have
fractions on fractions but I can still
continue with this in whichever of these
forms that I've got and I can still
write it in a simpler way
can someone suggest to me what's
something I could do yeah 1 over X
divided by this so are you saying yep
okay let's follow this rabbit trail
shall we so I'm dividing by something
with some fractions in it right so you
guys know when you divide by a fraction
you can change that if you were dividing
by 1/5 you could change that to be
multiplying by multiplying by the it's
not to have an odd what's that a proper
word for it the reciprocal very good so
I could do that and in fact I will do
that in a second the catch is this thing
is not one single fraction this doesn't
have a reciprocal it's got bits in it so
how do I put together okay yep okay so
you're suggesting we want to put these
two together right in the same way that
we had these two fractions is that what
you're suggesting what something else
the numerator 1 in the denominator 1
this guy yeah hmm I'm not entirely sure
I'm following you hold on you can ask
what you're trying to do are you trying
to put these guys together or are you
trying to do something else okay I'm
gonna come back to your something
because I think I'm following with you
now but at the moment I'm gonna follow
down I want to finish this line of
reasoning that we've been suggested to
it and then we'll come back to your idea
and we'll see why in a second so if I
want to divide by this fraction I've got
to get it as one fraction and then I'll
do this right I'll turn upside down and
turn tomalak Asian so how can I write
this is one fraction rather than as two
things what I do set again I'm gonna
look for the lowest common multiple all
over again right now this is 1 over 1 I
want both denominators to be X so
instead of writing 1 over 1 I'm gonna
write it as X over X do you agree with
that like that's that's one isn't it do
you agree with that ok and now I have a
common denominator the lowest common
multiple of X and one happens to be X ok
so now I've got this let's see X plus 1
or X how's that that's ok I'll cool now
I can do that thing we said before I can
divide I can multiply by the reciprocal
so I'll write multiplication instead and
the reciprocal of course is X on 1 plus
X X plus 1 sorry I don't know why I
change that order okay what can I do now
yeah I can multiply it now once I put
these together these are gonna become
one fraction right and you notice
there's this common factor on the top of
the bottom and so they can cancel out
can't they which is kind of nice so you
can just say that's 1 on 1 plus X 2 or X
plus 1 I'll put it back to the order
that I originally wrote it in can we
simplify this any further or are you
happy with that
hmm how did I get from here to here I
cancelled these exes we're on the top
and the bottom right because I know once
I've got them combined into one fraction
I'm going to search for common factors
between the numerator in the delay and
then orchids all the amount okay and I
might as well do that now I can cancel
them out as soon as I see them lined up
with each other now this is okay right
I'm happy with this answer we don't
usually like negatives in our
denominators but I don't know where this
is negative or not because I've got no
idea where X is so I'm just gonna leave
that where it is but there's something
we can do and this is coming back to the
suggestion we're having before there's
something we can do right from the first
line that would make this a lot easier
and it's what I want to highlight in
this particular question there's lots of
ways to go about these different lot
different paths to these questions but
some are easier and less error-prone
than others see how you've got fractions
on the top in the bottom right and I
said oh that's gross I don't like having
factions of infractions so we went down
this path to get rid of the fractions on
fractions but there's another thing you
can do I'm gonna write down just like
before do you notice that there's
fractions on the top and the bottom they
both have the same denominator you
notice that yeah so what I can do in
fact is I can multiply through by the
same thing on the top of the bottom that
doesn't change things right we've
already established if you multiply by 3
on 3 same fraction right multiply by 2
on 2 same fraction what might be a
something on something that I could
multiply by that would get rid of both
of those fractions in one fell swoop any
suggestions I'll give you a tip it's not
2 on 2 and it's not 3 & 3
yeah if I multiply by the reciprocal of
1 over X which is just X multiplying by
reciprocal is a great idea because it
just completely cancels out whatever is
on the denominator watch what happens
what's 1 on X times its reciprocal
what is any number times its reciprocal
it's just 1 what happens on the bottom
here well don't forget the X multiplies
my both of these terms so 1 times X
gives you
the X and then 1 X times X gives you was
that more work or less work than before
that was dramatically less right now we
arrived at the same point we arrived at
the same answer which is always
reassuring you're like okay whichever
way I went I'm gonna get get there but
this is clearly more time consuming more
worrisome for me than the fact that it's
kind of time consuming is that it's very
error-prone the more things you are
doing the more places that you open up
yourself to make a silly little mistake
you know how this is in exams okay